and we're live welcome to the podcast
this is the podcast
so where is the thing that we're gonna
do what are we gonna do
what do you mean let's do it all right
uh here we are
we doing it
you're a little are we doing it I think
I should bring you up a little bit yeah
maybe a tiny bit yeah I'm gonna smidge
you up and oh smidge me up on the video
I think the video is good
but I appreciate your attention to
detail
you're a regular Martin Scorsese
all right
yes okay are you gonna keep the fan on
oh I heard a [__] pop-up what do you
think about the uh the audio the video
for me it looks like it's a little slow
it's a little slow
notice the slowness do you think like
this is a good test to see it how slow
it is
yeah you're missing frames there
that's a nice camera this one I guess is
not as nice no maybe we'll need to get
another one not as much met for video
yeah this is more like a camera for
pictures and photos I've seen a lot of
Asian Taurus with those types of cameras
yes yes they're they're Hefty they got a
lot of lens a lot of it is meant for
taking photos Yeah by volume
look how much stuff they brought to take
photos that's how important photos are I
steal the post every picture I take I
just do a peace sign I like it it's
non-threatening yeah it's gay you don't
really it's like American flies too
divided peace peace is like a world you
know if you generally do an American
flag in a photo I'm just saying you know
it's a non-political it's a
non-political gesture most gestures are
non-political except for the Black Fist
and the middle finger is if I paint just
my fist with shoe polish and put that in
there is that not okay
and you can black this do the n-word
with your fist or what kind of like is
that not you can always do it just be
like this my white power oh yeah
do you think that uh the audio is good I
think it sounds pretty good okay yeah
here are tiny buzz but I want to say
that's headphones related
yeah there's a buzz
so I've got a buzz about me and the
comedy shows people are saying that I'm
assaulting women that's the buzz on me
the buzz on me is the alcohol in my body
because I'm buzzed yeah dude
call me Buzz Lightyear because there's a
buzz in my audio equipment these are new
arms these are new mics those are new
arms sure sm7b's you have surgery on
them
what happened to your old ones
no I like jokes
what was I gonna look up
you think this is good I can't oh I was
gonna look up this podcast that we're
doing you're gonna look up a different
person a text to come here nice
that's good chat you got a chat going
don't show me that dude no one's really
in it cool
uh what do you want to do you want to
talk about comedy it's your pod beer
whatever you want to do you want to be
Earnest comedy is an art form and a
craft I like to think of it myself as a
philosopher really when I'm up there I
have to think of myself as a
velociraptor yes I've seen your actors a
lot of dinosaur act outs I've seen your
authentic self really yeah because
that's how you do comedy is by being
authentic not by being an act not this
guy it's total act you act like you have
shitty jokes and tell them awkwardly
yeah it's a it's a well thought out it's
got that's what it's really hurtful how
many times that's a really hurtful thing
to do oh that's it's funny because
people say you're a good writer so if I
say you're a shitty writer then it's
like oh everything else is just false
and then I say you're a bad performer
and that one goes under the radar yeah
you were being really nice to me before
this this is like when you're when a
girl show up and two guys are together
and you're gonna be mean to me in front
of you yeah well look at this guy yeah I
remember when I was like you back in the
days when I was younger I am a shitty
performer but I think that you know
people people like it people relate to
it I hate performers performers are all
the worst
yeah
I mean I agree because I can't do it so
I'm gonna obviously is that why you
agree or is it because you're
intellectually minded and intelligent
and beautiful
yeah I think it's a mixture
I do think I'm a little too I think I
gotta choose ugly or hot on stage that's
the thing I've been struggling or hot I
can't be in this Middle Ground anymore
why don't you just choose to just be
yourself
I guess how many years do I got to be
here losing money before I decide to try
something else though what is the what
do you think 14. okay so when I'm
43. I'll try something else when you're
72 you should give up and die
okay but I mean if as long as you're
living why not I'd like to make a call
do it a black and white picture of you
when you're 72 you should give up and
die Hans Kim so this is obviously not an
ideal Society yes and therefore not an
ideal comedy community okay so what does
that look like to you what do you think
that the road to stardom should look
like should look like yes uh I think a
lot more white guys should get chances
uh especially ones that say racial
racist and homophobic things I I would
appreciate it those guys would get
bolstered so financially where do you
think the money comes in and how do you
think it's divided
um
I don't know producers take a ton of
money and give you 20 but at the same
time I would never do any of the
producing that they do and the
successful ones I guess kind of deserve
the money but it would be cool if better
Comics could make enough cash in the
scene to like be here all the time like
New York like you do like six spots and
make like 200 bucks or like 100 that
would be cool well as long as the money
is going to landlords and you know the
[__]
owners and it's not going to the
comedians it's just inefficient and like
the bar
the bar people
but it's like if you if you don't have a
dream and you're pursuing something uh
that's more career oriented than just
making money then you need that money
and if you're having the art and the
dream then you don't need the money
because you're having creative
freedom and like hope of future success
yeah it's like people who program and
develop video games they often like go
to a different field like Dental
software because the video game guys
they're exploited because it's like
their dream to develop world Warcraft
but like no one wants to do medical
software yeah so they ended up getting
like underpaid even like huge people
that are important to big companies so
you know it is what it is I guess
um yeah I mean I think it's unfortunate
but I think if everyone is taken care of
like through just Universal Health Care
and just like welfare and just like
housing and food then you don't have to
pay the bartenders and waiters that much
and then because they're all being taken
care of I'm a [__] board you know
that I lost my [__] job all that
money can go to The Comedians and the
people that are actually doing the thing
that is bringing people in yeah no for
sure I mean I I just lost my job and
it's a real no fault of my own it's a
real bummer yeah it's like your life is
different and changed and it's the
outside powers that are doing it to you
and you don't like the feeling of
the interference from the outside world
and I worked full-time for before I
start comedy and then I kind of started
doing part-time like shortly after and
it's wild that if you you either have
two choices you work 40 hours a week and
you have some rights like Severance or
whatever or pregnancy [__] or you work
part-time and you just are disposable
you have no rights it's like there's no
middle ground where it's like can I just
have some protection like could I get
800 bucks extra on my next my last check
because the company sold the building
for eight million dollars and took me
out of a job one week in advance
but you know unless I'm gonna get a gun
and go down there yeah I mean what are
you gonna do go down there and protest
it's like I'm ready to go to the state
Captain there's not enough rights for
you and workers and part-time people
um
but you know what do you expect from a
country that was founded on slavery yeah
and they use that fear of people
exploiting you know my dad will be like
like The Welfare Queen thing so like
anytime they want to give anybody
anything Obama films it's always the
fear of some people are going to use it
that shouldn't instead of being like all
right well 10 of people are abusing it
but 90 of people are single mothers yeah
it's like isn't that still a pretty good
use of money I'm sure and also you can
claw it back through taxes yeah but then
no you can't tax the rich because the
rich earned it they deserve it because
they worked for it because workers
weren't allowed to collectively bargain
and unionize and that's the natural
order of things that's the way it should
be rich people it should just have a lot
of power to just enslave people and have
a plantation and
get rich off people
because that's normal and new unions and
people working together that's cheating
what do you think about flattening by
the rules like I've heard this I'm I all
I hear is little things I don't delve
into [__] I'm really dumb so I've heard
the flat tax thing levied like everyone
just paid 10 including billionaires no
like loopholes what have you ever like
thought about is that bad or good you
tell me you're smarter than me flat
taxes are a current
indoctrination of the cephas
cephalus
IA syphilis
I don't know
if you have if you have a STD that's you
can't get rid of like herpes like me you
shouldn't have to pay taxes that's my
tax your taxes you have or if you give
someone herpes you should have to pay
them like alimony for the rest of their
life so that [__] you gave me her Pace
can pay my rent yeah it's just a vicious
cycle it's just one original herpes
person just paying out it was my mom I
got it in the womb so really I just have
it on my face I don't have my pen or yet
your face was in your mom's [__] yeah
all up in it
how does that make you feel
kind of uncomfortable I guess but uh
I don't even really put my face in
my girlfriend's supposed to say that's
what happened to my mom's book all these
guys are talking eating [__] is fun I
mean it's all right there's a camera
there oh look at that delay
is [__] up my act out it's like a
light beer I'll have one but like I'd
rather have something else you know what
I mean as far as it's putting his [__]
eating goes you don't like eating [__]
I mean if it's on sale then I would do
it let's say that do you like the
results that it produces sometimes but
my girlfriend is hard to please let's
say which uh she's got a nanny well most
of the girlfriends I've been with are
quote hard to please because I'm not
quote like good at sex but this one's
especially hard so it feels like I put a
lot of work in and then it's like meh
yeah and uh well luckily we're recording
this so she's gonna see this
um I would say like maybe that's the
kind of women you attract is like the
heart to Pleasers and then you're just
really good at the struggle of like not
being fully there and just like the
middle Zone and that's just you guys
just live in that zone yeah
that sounds about right we can have a
little more success lately I think
orgasmically yeah well I mean like a few
a year is a big that's like right here
yeah so if I can get into like double
digits this year that would be that'd be
big news so what are you gonna do
differently uh you just you know
you just gotta you gotta show it's like
a basketball player just show up every
day you just put in the work and you
start seeing results eventually you know
what I mean okay that's fun I mean
you're getting to know her you're
getting closer you guys are figuring out
each other's bodies yes we are for sure
almost two years now I started dating
her right when I moved here well it's
something that she does that makes you
orgasm uncontrollably like anything I or
I can come like very easily I have a
huge problem huge uh premature
ejaculation problem really is that kind
of feel good though when you do it and
you're like oh honestly it feels better
if I can not because then I feel like
the if I just I could just come in like
a minute it doesn't feel that good it's
just like there's no sensitivity from my
own life is I've been inside a vagina
doing the sex and then I want to come
yeah and then I hold it in okay and then
it's just sort of like thumps inside of
my scrotum oh
and then I'm like I didn't come and now
I'm losing the boner that that feels
like it would hurt so the worst of Both
Worlds like I should have just come
instead of trying to hold it in the two
things I do are want to pinch my thigh
really hard so I'm like having sex with
her I'll just sneakily put my and I'll
just pinch my thigh and the other one I
do is I'll say I want to hit my ball
real quick I can't do it my girlfriend
actually not a stoner but when you're
[__] A Stoner you can say you're
gonna hit the ball and also being high
as [__] kind of this helps with the
premature so it's like a double sword so
you're like hey let's take a smoke break
yeah like every 15 after three humps
it's like gonna hit that one I don't
know man I mean sometimes I do okay I'm
selling myself a little short but not
really girls think I say this on a first
date they think because I'm saying I'm
bad at sex I must be good at it and then
they find out I was just being honest
and it's kind of funny because it's like
I told you so bad at sex what is it that
you think you do during the sex that
makes it bad I think I just don't have
enough uh after a few minutes of doing
most things I'm kind of over it so I'm
bored and you know I'm just not totally
present there I'd really just be like oh
my God I'm inside a vagina this is
theoretically the coolest thing I could
be doing right now anything else would
be a downgrade I should probably do I'd
probably just say that about a lot of
things but the thing with my girlfriend
is I always say to myself like if it was
because sometimes I deny sex
because it was just a matter of climbing
on top of her and humping for two
minutes and coming then yeah I would do
it all the time every day but now it's
like a thing where if I do that it makes
her feel certain typical so I have to be
like totally like engaged and ready and
just use her like a masturbation tool
yeah so I like have to like pick my
spots where I'm feeling up to the task
of sort of and then she's and then she
says that you should want to do that to
make me feel good I'm like of course I
do but you I don't want to go out and
play basketball all the [__] time I
like my best you know what I mean I
don't like the pressure it's like oh we
have to have six three times a day then
it's like oh here we go but she's
getting better at not pressuring because
once you get upset if I deny her that
becomes like a bigger pressure that like
and then it makes you premature thing
girls are told that men are horny animal
dogs and then when a man rejects her for
sex even though it's just a human thing
to not always need to or have to or be
able to have sex and she's like oh my
God
that's so sad yeah even men don't want
me it's like I'm gonna just go to the
bus stop and pick up a homeless yeah to
feel desired and wanted because Paul is
distracted after two minutes of sex yeah
she's thinking about Super Smash
Brothers yeah it's always kind of been
an issue I think in relationships a
month that's why I don't hook up with
girls because well honestly the only
thing a girl can really ask of you is
for you to [__] you know make her
come to the best of her abilities three
times a year three times a year and then
also to just come yourself yes whatever
you have to do to get that to happen no
problem with that I'm always there I'm
batting a thousand I would say in our
sexual me in a girl maybe one time ever
you don't like to start it because it's
a lot of work uh I mean I'll start it
but yeah I I once heard Mark Norman say
something like you know it's like part
of being closeness in a relationship so
I just have to like
have it in my mind to like set time
aside or think like when I get home I'm
gonna you know
uh start something like and not because
if I just ignore it like anything I'll
just won't ever do it for like what is
this like you're a time when you had sex
and you were like
oh my God
I just did that embarrassing thing
uh one time I drove to Western Mass to
have sex with this Asian girl who's like
19 and then how old are you I was
probably like 25 or something like that
and then it was she was on Tinder and
she just straight up was like come here
and she was so hot that I thought I was
gonna get there and then she wasn't
gonna be there and then she walked out
at the front door to get me from my car
and I thought I'll probably get mugged
by her friends one side you know what I
mean it was just one of those things how
are you preparing for getting mud I just
accepted like I'm gonna get hit yeah
tuck the head give them the money yeah
anything that you were gonna keep and
fight to the death to keep no I mean I I
don't know I don't even know I just got
out and got but I just had this feeling
that there's no way it's this easy
because it usually is not yeah and then
we had some we watched a racer head and
the beginning scene is this really slow
Zoom I think on the moon or something
and we already started hooking up before
it was that uh I think it was her she's
a weird most of the girls I hook up with
are really [__] weird and then so you
attract because you're such a artiste
you're such a sensitive boy yeah uh and
then we hooked up a little bit and then
I ended up driving home that night
okay I texted her a huge thing saying I
had such a good time and all this [__]
and uh it was really embarrassing in
retrospect like
to send this along because I really
wanted to hook up with her again and I
should have just not I should have been
like thanks for having I just sent like
a two paragraph thing about how and then
she just never text me back but you were
you fumbled fumbled so hard yeah you
were like just be like it was awesome I
would love to do that again sometime if
you ever would yeah I decided to do that
again I've done [__] like that a lot in
my life I came inside a girl named
Circle back to you
I'll have my people contact your people
I ride a girl named Oak fist one time
and I came inside of her and then I say
I was drunk and I say I was like you
should not be coming inside people with
names like that under any circumstance
Oak fist her parents neighbor oakfist
she's her parents are from Portland well
isn't it cool that when you're young and
hot you have so much power and then
people act weird and you're like ew
gross let me reject weirdness and then
you can just
cut that out of your life yeah and it's
like that was quick and easy I can just
cut out the disgusting parts and just
keep the good parts and then you get
drunk with that power and you just start
cutting and cutting until soon you're 40
and you're all alone and sad I think
that's part of the reason I sort of
detached my brand from wanting to be a
[__] Hound like after being out here
and seeing all the comics do it it's fun
to for one or two of the girls I hooked
up with when I first moved here before I
started doing Alyssa they were with my
friend and a girl that he was hooking up
with it was just a friend of theirs and
they were like aggressive towards like
saying that they thought I was cute and
I was very like dismissive like I don't
care and then that makes them Wanna [__]
you more or whatever right but I'm
honestly doing it it's not a game yeah
it's not a game it's just like that
allows them to go fully indulge into
their desire and it makes them feel like
they won after they sleep with you and
I'm not doing it as a game but it's like
it tends to get me laid more than like
trying to get when I triulated very
rarely works out if I'm ignoring someone
for a long well thanks for being on the
podcast what the hell dude what 19
minutes what's wrong with 19 minutes
that's fine it's me it's your podcast I
mean I thought it was a fire 19. Jesus
Christ